if regards our deal migration we have
managed to reach an agreement in the
European Council but this is in fact the
easiest part of the task compared to
what awaits us on the ground
when we start implementing it as for the
text of our compromise the leaders
accepted three proposals I put forward
that is disembarkation platforms outside
Europe dedicated budgetary tool in the
next mff to combat illegal migration as
well as boosting EU support for the
Libyan Coast Guard on top of that we
have sent a clear message to all vessels
including those of NGOs operating in the
Mediterranean that they must respect the
law and must not obstruct the operation
of the Libyan Coast Guard another part
of the compromises the franco-italian
proposal of controlled centres on EU
territory in countries that are willing
to build them all the measures in the
context of these centres including
location and resettlement will be taken
on a voluntary basis last but not least
we agreed to launch the next tranche of
financing for Turkey and to transfer 500
million euros of development money to
the EU trust fund for Africa moving on
to this morning's proceedings the euro
summit agreed as promised in December to
progress on the completion of the
banking union and to strengthen the
European Stability Mechanism this reform
of the EMU will strengthen the euro and
of the result also our union in
turbulent times this is welcome news for
all Europeans on brexit the hue 27 has
taken note of what has been achieved so
far if you want to reach at the
in October we need quick progress this
is the last call to lay the cards on the
table